wandavision is the mcu's weirdest
project to date
full of very obvious sitcom references
and more than a few
subtle hints that something in wanda's
world is very
very wrong the third episode is no
different here's a few small details
that may have passed you by
prior to the release of wandavision the
last time we saw
scarlet witch she was tearing thanos
apart single-handedly
posing for a group shot and chatting
with clint barton after tony stark's
funeral
that's where we left her an end game but
in this show her main challenge
seems to be in the realm of new
beginnings while working on her nursery
wanda unintentionally makes the
butterflies of the mobile above the crib
turn
into actual butterflies this is a
reference to a popular marvel comics
mini series and could even be the
foreshadowing for a character who has
yet to be revealed
kicking already wow oh it's such a
strange
sensation it's kind of fluttery one of
the comic book series fans have been
comparing most to one division
is the 2005 mini series house of m
in fact paul bettany has said
wandavision was pitched to him
specifically as a mashup of the comic
books
vision and house of m in the latter
series
wanda uses her reality warping powers to
completely remake the world
with a few noteworthy exceptions here
and there most of the people
in this new reality have no idea the
world's been remade
but one of the exceptions is layla
miller who comes to be known as
you guessed it butterfly layla is a
mutant before house of m
and somehow wanda's reality warping
gives her the ability to awaken people
into the knowledge that they're living
in a world gone wrong nor do we think
that this is the last time leila is
referenced in episode 3
when they're talking about what to name
who they assume will be their newborn
son
wanda jokes about hoping it's a girl
later when vision practices changing a
diaper
he uses a girl doll with blonde hair
just like leila
in spite of the fact that he and wanda
seem to be sure
their child will be a boy the episode
also keeps up the trend of breaking up
the action with a surreal
fake commercial episode three's
advertisement pulls from old commercials
for calgon
a water softening brand with a line of
bath and beauty products
in the 70s and 80s there was a popular
series of advertisements
in which overworked over-stressed women
would throw their hands up
and beg for deliverance from the calgon
brand
that does it
after uttering the magic phrase they
would be transported to a bathtub
where they would be overcome with
comfort in this ad
a busy mother can't even eat her
breakfast without her kids knocking her
cereal away with a soccer ball
a dog reminiscent of visions pet sparky
from the vision comic
minus the green fur feeds against the
wall then the narrator asks her
do you need a break you read my mind
which is of course something that wanda
can literally do
the woman in the commercial is
transported to a bubble bath where a man
in a roman
toga fans her like a doting servant
among other things
the narrator says when you want to get
away but you don't want to go anywhere
which could be a description of what's
happening to wanda and vision
he also speaks of a place where your
problems float away
which evokes the way in which wanda
makes things float away with her mind
the mom likewise blows bubbles off her
hands as if she has
similar powers finally the product is
revealed
hydra soak the slogan is find the
goddess within
it's a clear reference to the powers
hydra gave wanda
and the fact that those powers are
clearly expanding it's also intriguing
that the product box reads
made in usa since that's not where hydra
was formed
nor is it where wanda was when she was
given her powers
three episodes in wandavision is a
series full of mysteries large and small
whether that small detail ends up adding
up to anything remains to be seen
until then we're just sitting back on
the couch and enjoying the ride
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one